Bayne: Hi, my name
is Michael Bayne.
I'm the CTO
of Three Rings,
and also the lead engineer
on Whirled,
which is the project
that I want to show you today.
We used the Google Web Toolkit
to build Whirled.
Whirled is a social
virtual world Web site,
um, which means that it's part
social networking Web site,
and it's part
virtual world.
As a social networking Web site,
we have a lot of things
that you would come
to expect.
Uh, there's a feed
that tells you
what your friends
have been up to.
You have friends.
Those friends have profiles.
Um, you can be
members of groups.
In the groups,
there are discussion boards,
so you can talk
to people about things
that are going on
in the world.
Um, you can send people mail.
You know,
we have photo galleries,
and all sorts
of stuff like that.
And then it's also
part virtual world,
which is a little more like
massive multiplayer
online games.
You have an avatar.
You're wandering around
in virtual spaces.
We can go and find some people
here and talk to them.
Howdy, guys.
Everything kind of happens
in real time.
Um, and there's also, um,
games that you can play
with people
in the virtual world.
It's kind of
a casual games Web site
on top of all these
other things.
So here we can see
one of our games
called Corpse Craft.
It's a pretty popular one
where you play
this little puzzle game,
and you--in doing that,
you reanimate corpses,
and then you
send them to go
and destroy the base
of your enemy.
We used GWT to build
the social networking Web site
part of Whirled.
Um, and it's done a lot
of the heavy lifting
for us there,
which has been
really great.
Um, it has a module system,
and we broke Whirled up
into a bunch of little modules,
and then we put it
all together
into actually
a bunch of different
little GWT applications.
And having the ability to factor
everything out like that
has been a huge bonus.
Uh, we also use
the internationalization system,
uh, which is great.
Hopefully the Whirled will
someday take over the world.
Um, and that has
saved us some time.
And we've also even been able
to extend that
using GWT's generators to do
some sort of custom stuff
that we needed.
We've also been able to use
third-party libraries
very easily
when we need to do
drag and drop.
Or if we need
to use a date-picker widget,
then we can integrate someone
else's third-party library
without a whole lot
of headache.
Um, and Whirled's
actually grown quite a lot
over the last two years,
and it's now about 60,000 lines
of code
just for the client.
And so being able
to sort of enforce the same kind
of engineering discipline
that we do
everywhere on the project
has been a huge help
in keeping the client
from turning
into a sort of hairy mess.
It's also great to be able
to use Java on the client
and the server.
We also use ActionScript
on the project,
and when we have to coordinate
between Java and ActionScript,
it's really kind of a pain.
And so not having
that extra pain
when we're doing the client
is a huge benefit.